how to instantiate a transformers model
in this video we'll look at how we can
create and use the model from the
transformers library
as we've seen before the auto model
class allows you to instantiate a
pre-trained model
from any checkpoint on the interface up
it will pick the right model class from
the library to instantiate the proper
architecture
and load the weights of the pre-trained
model inside
as we can see when given a bird
checkpoint
we end up with a bird model and
similarly for gpd2 or part
behind the scenes this api can take the
name of a checkpoint on the hub
in which case it will download and cache
the configuration file
as well as the model rates file you can
also specify the path
to a local folder that contains a valid
configuration file
and a modal waste file to instantiate
the retrain model
the auto model api will first open the
configuration file
to look at the configuration class that
should be used
the configuration class depends on the
type of the model
bert gpt2 or part for instance
once it has a proper configuration class
it can instantiate that configuration
which is a blueprint to know how to
create the model
it also uses this configuration class to
find the proper model class which is
then combined with the loaded
configuration
to load the model this model is not yet
a pre-trained model
as it has just been initialized with
random weights
the last step is to load the width from
the model file
inside this model to easily load the
configuration of a model from any
checkpoint or folder containing the
configuration file
we can use the autoconfig class
like the auto model class it will pick
the right configuration class from the
library
we can also use a specific class
corresponding to a checkpoint
but we'll need to change the code each
time we want to try a different model
architecture
as we said before the configuration of a
model is a blueprint
that contains all the information
necessary to create the module
architecture
for instance the birth model associated
with the pert base case
checkpoint has 12 layers a hidden side
of 768
and a vocabulary size of 28 996
once we add the configuration we can
create a model that has the same
architecture as our checkpoint
but is randomly initialized we can then
training from scratch like any by torch
model
we can also change any part of the
configuration by using keyword arguments
the second snippet of code instantiates
a randomly initialized birth model with
10 layers
instead of 12. saving a model once it's
trained or fine-tuned is very easy
we just have to use the safe retrain
method
here the model will be saved in a folder
named my belt model
inside the current working directory
such a model can then be reloaded using
the front pre-trained method
to learn how to easily upload this model
to the lab check out the push to app
video
you